un trade religieuse de jeunes vierges de
penser qu' à 2763 euros arlette
laguiller
maintenant faut donner dix fois plus
souvent x 100 ma cassette personnelle
well as une conscience politique
geneviève un jeune bien ça serait bien
public à endemol on se fait une arrivée
dites moi je les riches peuvent payer
comment les riches peuvent payer donc
vous êtes riche d'un voyage voilà alors
j'avais invité arlette laguiller ce soir
dans cette émission et c'est interdit
vous savez qu'au moment où les gens vont
voter oui on attend les hommes
politiques dans les émissions c'est
démocratique parce que c'est le seul
moment on aura envie d écouter ci au
moment où on va voter bascons la csa
nous l'interdît vous savez ça ridicule
ou trouvés sont antidémocratiques ont
été refaits de près faire la révolution
avec moi oui y'a quand même y'a un truc
que vous devez savoir quand même c'est
que si arlette laguiller arrive au
pouvoir
les miss france ça sera interdite quand
même parce que pour elle c'est vraiment
un symbole inacceptable encore président
de la république mais imaginez qu'elle
arrive à force du financement là je
serai dans l'eau boueuse ici à d'accord
bien alors donc vous avez vendu mais
vous serez toujours le chaperon demis
arias je vous étiez pas là je sais pas
de quoi on parlerait à la télé ça non
mais c'est vrai c'est une star
récurrente des émissions de télévision
à commencer par celle là qui va
l'histoire ce qui vous oppose à la lame
de fond guérilla vous êtes gérant de
fontenay je trouve que c'est pas ça le
rythme article
manifester le ratio
louis de fontenelle mary jane bien y
regarder la télé mais pas sa phase
giscard mitterrand il manger une tartine
de confiture
il meurt 16 mars 80 et avait mis quoi
dans la confiote comme moi si vous savez
il faisait partie serait pas aussi mal
élevés je ne laisserai pas dire du magic
xavier oui avec javier est un ami ça m'a
fait très plaisir le jour thierry
bearish moi l'idée chez son beau père
parce que service sophie thalmann elle
dit qu'un jour elle est invitée à dîner
chez geneviève de fontenay et pour
manger une boîte d'origine
scott une soupe enfin franchement c'est
vrai moi et enfin que vaille à carmaux
en ce qui concerne le livre moi je
dirais que c'est l'ingratitude et un
manque de recrues dit qu il y avait elle
dit que je ne viendrais et xavier son
radar mais je connais bien je me suis
trop content d'aller poste rooney mais
détourné à q est ce que c'est que cette
histoire quand on triche ou seriez
radine alors que bouffer quand on sait
ce qu'on peut vous gagner quand on sait
jouer gagner francs par mois vous êtes
expliquer tous les deux avec je n'aime
pas m'expliquer avec lui pourquoi
penser
jetant pas dire sa fierté ce qu'on peut
dire tout de suite c'est que non c'est
vrai c'est lui voulait beaucoup vous
aviez nous et xavier moi c'est une
grande histoire
oui toutes les miss france adore xavier
tromper c'est dû à quoi
le match est allergique j'ai eu au
téléphone
à l'époque elle était en larmes
franchement je sais pas si elle était
pénible ce qui est l'élection miss
france
quinze jours après et ça fait quand même
le tour des médias
et c'était pas mal ça fait plus pour
l'élection de miss france donc
finalement je l'aï eu en ligne après
elle m'a dit finalement d'areva c'était
pas si mal que ça
coke et j'aime bien
monsieur là
quelques rondes
pour le vélo de michel drucker
alors non je n'y ai alors sérieusement
maintenant sérieusement c'est vrai que
vous avez eu affaire à de sacrés
pistolet comme on dit chez moi la plus
cachottière ses sept nains comme nymphes
oman vous l'avez su après oui je sais
que dans l'ancien à part mais dites moi
je n'en fais mal c'est une ashkénaze et
etienne s'est avéré d'une qualité
pardon ça peut être une qualité ouais
vous pensez que xavier a été victime de
cette fille en vie dans ce domaine
absolument irréprochable il reprochait à
poser c'est grave ce que vous dites mais
qui trop irréprochable des puceaux on
veut il est marié à les maris les deux
petites filles qu'elles sont didier
agathe et nl bien la plus insolente
mareva galanter oui en arriva j'aime
bien ma rivale elle a trouvé un bon
parti m'arriva castelbajac
ouais elle a connu grâce à nous ouais
mais c'est bien pour sinon à se presser
pour des ministres en seraient toujours
autour de soins bon bah oui je serai là
bas
non franchement elle a trouvé oui c'est
qu'elle abandonné c'est qu'elle
abandonnait philippe le capitaine du
yacht labama je crois ou le groupe k il
s'est retrouvé du jour au lendemain la
finale
bon alors voilà après bon la plus
ingrate on a déjà dit sophie thalmann de
temps franchement c'est à dire que
j'invite à dix naissances 2 et el oued
pour deux boutons pour le enfin parce
que les jeunes femmes blanches dans
certains cantons manche membres alors la
rue pour miss france une boîte de temps
la pluie la plus nulle sonia rolland non
non c'est pas vrai alors je veux dire
que ça a été ma reda oui alors désormais
je le dis à toutes les heures toutes les
filles qui veulent être miss france a
désormais il est interdit quand on est
miss france de poser nue pendant cinq
ans sinon on a 300 mille francs d'amendé
destiné à eliane colis destinés à une
joue et il était d'accord avec ce artur
mas avait eu demande pas son avis et
c'est ce que je veux vous avez vendu
maintenant vendu mon âme moi j'ai bien
vendu est vrai que ces gens là ils
n'achètent pas votre attendez on est un
protocole d'accord entre la société miss
france et le comité miss on est d'accord
et je garde des bons avocats et au
maître jean-philippe destremau a fait ça
avec un bon grand art d'accord ok non
parce que dans le monde il faudrait pas
qu'ils vous disent qu'il faut faire non
plus je dois faire c'est un milieu très
dur à le milieu des murs et non c'est
mieux le milieu de l'amitié de la nature
vous avez dit j'avais dit oui sophie
thalmann a dit que vous étiez une peau
de vache
oui nos élèves à ma vie que j'avais été
une plage et jeunes bien là dit en
parlant de la diana miss sylvie tellier
j'espère j'espère que c'est pas une
jolie fleur dans une peau de vache et
par hasard mais qu'est ce que j'ai dit
c'est tous les ans j'ai dit j'espère que
la nouvelle miss rang ne sera pas une
jolie fleur dans une peau de vache
voilà n'ai pas dit spécialement pour ça
mais pourquoi ces conditions la vache
alors j'aime bien qu'on connaît pas
encore bien sylvie tellier charmante et
je vous aiderai moment avec je ne fais
que répéter vos paroles je viens vous
avez dit je ne veux pas envoyer tout de
suite ma miss dans les émissions de
ruquier ou d'ardisson je préfère que ma
miss haidar al habitude de la télévision
et est ce que maintenant elle est blindé
sylvie méry voire à les blindés à donner
avant qu'elles arrivent très bien oui
quand même vous préfériez niche
clairement dit non non je ne me perrier
miss l'entité côte d'azur vous essayez
raison maintenant un churchill vie vous
êtes une raison vas-y ramper me suis
trompé j'avoue et el bez
si vite
et voilà et voilà bonsoir on santé après
jolie fête dont j'ai gardé que je me
jetais grand panneau comme je ne suis
pas content quand elle a été très joli
mais qu'est ce qu'elle va plus mais ils
scrutent d'azur alors c'était donc le 8
décembre 2001 vicié miss lyon que vous
êtes devenue miss france
alors on va parler de vos mensurations
m'en voudrez pas parce que pour une
liste c'est la moindre des choses
mensurations 88 64 92 lundi c'est à
s'élever à peu près à peu près ça alors
quoi mais c'est la taille d'un problème
outre non parce qu'il ya des
contestations
on vous a suspecté de ne pas faire un
mètre 72 a pas je vous sais que les miss
doit faire un mètre 72
on a dû vous faisiez 68 71 attendait
bichard forez à compter ses nouvelles a
rempli sa fiche polémique et le désir m
et 72 elle faisait convient d'aller se
faire mesurer bêtement bahreïn huissier
qu'elle nie qu'elle a fait à mai 68
bêtement b n'ont remarqué toutes ces
histoires de contestation l'avait
rarement aperçue qu'elle ne dit que cela
était un homme ça n'a pas empêché les
soirs athènes grèce - c'est sa maman
rugby souvent une bonne raison de
réaliser un concours un nouveau je suis
plus longue pour emmerder comme on dit
c'est vrai finalement que j'ai entendu
que ledit site un homme
j'avais pas vu qu'elle était et miss
europe lequel est superbe c'est alors
bon c'est pas grave sans les mesures
dévoilées depuis je pense après tout
personne n'est parfait bien alors suivi
avant d'être miss france vous destiniez
à la profession d'avocate mairie voilà
vous avez fait des études à lyon vous ai
fait une maîtrise de droit
oui est ce que vous avez vraiment cette
maîtrise de droit
oui il ya un truc avant 81 18 vous
déclarez vivent toujours chez vos
parents aux sables d'olonne et en 2001
vous dites que vous êtes à lyon depuis
quatre ans je vais pas expliquez moi
comment c'est possible s'attendent à
1,98 j'ai fait mon deug de droit nantes
j'ai fait ma licence à ma maîtrise à
lyon d'accord donc si on calcule j'ai eu
ma maîtrise en juin 2001 donc je suis
arrivé à lyon des coups mais j'avais une
maîtrise le grand jeu ma carte étudiante
si vous voulez je les trie j'ai un
copain qui est dealer de shit mais en
étudiant la tribune
en quoi faire donc un tribunal hisser
aux grands pas du tout je ne viens bon
français mais y'avait
c'est le service public j'aime bien
parfait spectateurs alors pour rigoler
mais la mission nous alors vous avez
déclaré sylvie si je suis élue miss
france
le barreau m'attendre à genève pour lui
en même temps oui alors vous et des
propositions du cinéma de télévision non
ah bon dix garçons à maintenir la mecque
et celle le dit dans la presse alors
mais ouais 23 agents de nombreux parents
et ça c'est pas du tout le style de la
maison
nous avons témoigné don kelly dvd à
gagner si vous donnez le nom de lui
touche de gad elmaleh barrier dollar
contribue bien alors la mode des
propositions de la mode non plus photos
nues photo nue non des invitations à des
anniversaires ont été servis sonia
rolland j'ai très vite et j'ai pas pu
aller très bien serait chape et on est
très bien j'aime beaucoup ont enlevé ben
je sais pas je n'y viens chaque fois que
je la vois une union ses bras vrai avec
geneviève savard a aucun problème
vous aimez les boîtes de temps alors et
avec xavier les xavier se passe très
bien malheureusement vous avions vont
pas beaucoup dans l'année puisque
essentiellement évolué marina avenir
s'écrit que les rares fois où je vois
xavier se sont loin très sympa il est
venu m'apporter un petit cadeau pour
aménager mon studio lalalalalala métier
vous méfiez vous avec xavier c'est tout
juste
dites moi votre caractère problème
pas facile à a pas facile pour un père
ses bas quand ils ont préparé l'élection
de miss france à agadir vos copines ont
dit vous étiez froide hautaine voire
prétentieux s'il vit on
le ce sont les commentaires des 45 je
m'incline maintenant j'aimerais savoir
si c'est vraiment le commentaire des 45
candidats sont jalouses avait bien [ __ ]
d'une la même façon sympathy libye a
indiqué ne pas pouvoir bien alors pauvre
loulou maintenant on peut pas plaire à
tout le monde chez dc c'est vrai que
vous avez un petit peu une carapace
c'est bien ici d'une carapace pas passé
déjà quand il était tout petit et moi on
me disait toute façon ils disaient les
insondables et distante et ils disent
toujours très souvent dans les articles
sur les miss france c'est un truc qui me
frappe
si les encadrer dans les journaux des
accroches énorme où la miss dis
attention
je suis aussi intelligent enverrons un
article où j'ai dit je ne suis pas qu'un
joli ici à les y aller
non mais c'est vrai comme vous êtes à
24,04 attention presque avocats n'ont
pas presque parce que lorsque vous avez
maîtrisé droit ou non je suis peut-être
miss france mais je suis intelligent non
mais vous êtes presque avocate c'est
normal en même temps bon parce que vous
êtes un petit peu plus âgés que les
fields a dit voilà c'est tout les juges
ont 18 ans la whey n'ont jamais rien en
trois ans on est une fille qui a 18 ans
bac + 5 voilà c'est pas possible
ma fille bien alors maintenant on en
arrive au point crucial à l'amoureux
grave grave alors qu'il avait pas lyon
benzène et 30 août je suis désolée la
maire communiste qui peu décousu
pourquoi des cousines pas décousu parce
que bon elle est livrée à elle-même lui
c'est parce qu'elle fait aux besoins qui
ont passé savez désignant les plus
solides sont basées sur la confiance
c'est sûr bien chers bambins
maintenant oui bien sûr j'ai absolument
il est où c'est que je pense que les
gens non c'est ça on serra ne comptez
pas sur moi pour dire des trucs pareils
bon ton fiancé sa réfugié politique
ce que vous croyez
est ce que vous croyez sérieusement que
votre amour va survivre à un an de règne
non pas en fait si on n'a rien je pense
en tout cas celui d'elodie la serez q
pourquoi les marais genre ah ben ammar
et savez les tahitiennes sont
accueillantes
moi c'est vous que j'aurais acheté pour
faire quelque chose s'ils étaient armés